i'm ainsley earhart i'm charles payne
i'm martha mccallum and this
is the fox news rundown
friday january 1st 2021
i'm dave anthony happy new year
something we have
all been waiting to say and finally get
rid of the old one
and i think this year we have to make
that more profound
um in a sense where we're going to say
all right you know 2021
it has to be a better year than 2020. it
can't not be
lisa brady before the summer surge of
covid when many parts of the us were
reopening
spacex launched a key flight and renewed
dreams of space tourism which might
eventually
be within reach for people other than
millionaires
would you forego two years of saved
money for
vacations for one trip into space i bet
you will
i'm liz peake i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
did you wake up feeling different has a
weight been lifted off your shoulders
it's finally new year's day and we can
say good riddance to 2020.
something people have been wanting to do
for a while i mean it really
was a rough year for so many people the
pandemic cost a lot of lives and many
livelihoods
putting people out of work and putting a
lot of distance between us
and friends and family i didn't hug my
mom all year between travel bans and
covered fears and i know
i am hardly alone in that so we can all
hope
for a much better 2021 hope that the
vaccines
can finally end this pandemic and life
can return to normal
as we turn the page and maybe even
resolve to do something new
or do something better or do something
to make us
better people look at the at the new
year as as a brand new foundation right
start something new
let's uh let's start going to the gym
let's
take up a new goal a new activity
whatever it might be tom
kirsten is a licensed psychotherapist in
new jersey
so 2020 being probably the most
difficult year
uh maybe in history um i think a lot of
this is a very good opportunity for
people to look themselves in mirror and
say you know what
i have to put this past year behind me
and all i could do is look ahead i got
to
put 2020 in a rear view mirror and now
i'm looking through the windshield and i
am going to make
2021 the best year i possibly can
and the psychology behind that is it's
it's basically you know it's a it's a
it's an intentional mindset it's an
intentional sitting down with yourself
uh using some visualization uh
strategies uh
and seizing control of your thoughts
instead of them controlling you all
right so
when you say visualization strategies
you mean just
sit down and write it on paper and what
what are what are people supposed to
to think about well check this out right
so a lot of people don't really
understand how the mind works right so
the average person has its estimated
um sixty thousand thoughts per day right
so most of our thinking is is that
wandering daydreaming mind
and that and that's typically um you
know thinking that's in the past about
what has happened and and you know
filled with fear and despair and so
forth
so using you know visualization is a
conscious effort where you sit down you
only got to sit you could be in your car
it's just taking a breath of air and
becoming present in this moment and now
steering your thinking
having a little conversation a little
self-talk with yourself that you know i
am going to
um you know do a b c or d this upcoming
year so
you're essentially taking control of
thinking instead of your thinking taking
control of you which is how most of us
live
believe it or not well 2021 on the
calendar looks different but we're still
in the middle of this
pandemic we still don't have you know
this solved yet i know the vaccines are
going out and that's obviously important
but is it the psychology
is just changing the calendar just a
different viewpoint that helps
well i think there's a mental component
there um i remember before my gym which
actually shut down forever
um i was you know i go every day i've
been doing that for so many years and
every that first week of
you know after uh january 1st it's all
of a sudden there's like three times the
amount of people at the gym
sure and then it would and then all of a
sudden that would start fading away
so people look at the new year as as a
new beginning
um and i think this year we have to make
that more profound
um in a sense where we're going to say
all right you know 2021 is go
it has to be a better year than 2020. it
can't not be um
so it's sort of like you know the
mentality of of you know when when
you're when you're given lemons you make
a lemonade
um a lot of what we do is a mindset you
know yeah a lot of people have been hit
hard with this people on lockdown or in
shutdown but it
also depends how you how you look at
that you know one way of looking at that
is all right well
you know i've had more time to spend
with my family this year so we got to
try to take the
the positives with the negatives and
hopefully highlight the positives more
than the negatives
a lot of people are depressed about
politics right i mean we have a very
polarizing election
we have a change in who's going to be
the president
later on in january is is there
something
that people can do to get out of that
well you know
basically you know where are most people
getting a lot of their information well
they're they're sort of marinating their
minds
in social media all day long and i call
social media the tailpipe
of the mainstream media so you know
everybody now feels that they have some
some part in what's going on they could
give their opinions they could yell at
each other shout out to each other
right they mean things to one another
best thing to do is is um
how you know disconnect yourself from
social media and reconnect yourself with
your own being and your and your close
family members
um and kind of get back to planet earth
get out of that cyber world where
you know where your mind is literally
being hijacked and get back to the real
world spend time with your family
focus on your goals and aspirations for
you know people aren't going to stop
using their social media so what what do
you suggest they do
to pull back necessarily to find a way
to be
to do it less what's the what's the best
way the
best thing is to do a a stone cold detox
really social media yes 100 so make a
commitment to yourself of course we can
do that make a commitment to yourself
that
you know you are not going to be going
on you know whatever it is facebook
whatever site where you're
getting what you're making yourself all
upset um
a lot of people get their news every day
from that though tom a lot of people do
every day rely on that they do i mean
you know but
you get but that's you know go to news
sites then you know like social media
is is isn't really news it's more
people's opinions that they're kind of
spewing out there
and uh and then you're getting you know
all kinds of negative feedback and so
forth
um but you know a little detox doesn't
mean to escape forever just means to
ungrip yourself from the clutches
mentally of that stuff
um and what this will do dave is it'll
allow people to sort of um
to reset okay uh to now focus on
on their priorities to focus on what
they're grateful for um and it'll give
them it'll free up you know
hours of of time in a day where they're
where they're sort of hypnotized and
down this you know dark tunnel of social
media
and it'll get be able to hit the reset
button you hit a reset button
but it's tough to change your patterns
it's tough to change your behavior
why how does a resolution succeed i mean
so many fail
you talked about the gym people stopped
going after a few weeks of
this new resolution how do you make it
work
well here's the deal so you know we are
creatures of habit everything we do we
do the same way the way we walk the way
we shower the way
it feels good to do that right it's it's
part of the pattern routines
that's where our minds it's the way our
mind works you know we get into a
routine and now we don't need to think
anymore
our subconscious mind does it for us so
we have to do is kind of go
almost use some willpower initially so
to create a new habit
means you have to go against uh your
your instinct it feels uncomfortable
getting up at five o'clock in the
morning and going to that gym every day
but you have to force yourself to do
that for a good three to four weeks
until that now becomes a new habit
where it just becomes a routine that's
how our brain works that's how our mind
works psychologically
to form a new habit requires work
initially and then it becomes sort of a
gravy training becomes much easier
um so number one is you have to you know
tell yourself i am look yourself in the
mirror
and say i am going to do abc or day and
then do it no matter what happens if
that alarm goes up to five in the
morning
and and that your bed is it seems just
way too comfortable get get on your feet
before you can think
um and and start creating that new habit
is it sometimes that we're a little too
generic
in a resolution where it fails you know
this you're going to lose
10 pounds i'll lose 15 pounds that's a
goal
but i mean that's not something i'm
changing my patterns and behavior for me
every day yeah well even you know so
talk about something like weight loss
you know if if somebody if you say to
somebody hey you think you could lose
100 pounds
you know that dealt with many people
helping them lose weight um
oh my god that seems like so impossible
do you think he could lose 10. yeah i
think i could do that great we're going
to focus on 10.
anything we do is a reflection of what
we're thinking so that's the whole key
to taking control of thought you know
having a little mantra
repeating to us repeating to yourself
you know what i am going to lose 10
pounds in the month of january
and nothing is going to stop me i am
going to lose 10 pounds in a month of
january nothing's going to stop me
repetition for our mind is what is is is
what
would feel the deal inside our mind
subconsciously and we began we'll begin
to
our actions will will uh will be the
reflection of that
i've seen different uh ideas on
resolutions
and some people talk about changing your
space around you or
declutter or things like that does that
work
100 so our space around us right so if
we have clutter around us and so forth
those are called energy drainers
right they actually bring us down so
that that's a great example dave so you
know anybody listening right now let's
say that
you know your car is a mess all right
and you commute a lot in your car you
don't even realize the impact that's
having on you mentally
so go clean your car it creates a clean
mentality and a clean inside if your
room
your bedroom or your living room is a
mess clean it up um
decluttering those external things
declutters our mind and our emotions no
question about it now i also saw
that one of the lists suggested that one
of the resolutions could be to start
therapy and it made me wonder does
everybody
need therapy yeah well you know it's
interesting so i've been a therapist for
20 years in private practice and a lot
of people they have this assumption that
oh you know like i i
i you have to have problems to go to a
therapist right well i'm not crazy i
don't have to go
see a guy and what's interesting is
every person that comes in my office i
never look at
as having a problem i look at as having
a solution okay
so we've got to destigmatize that
realize that you know your purpose if
you're thinking of considering going to
see a therapist if two isn't because you
have problems and you're crazy
it's to improve yourself it's to
challenge yourself
all right it's to have somebody hold you
accountable teach you how to think the
correct way so you can establish that
new year's resolution
so that you can lose the 10 pounds so
you can can take the actions
to pursue whatever your career dreams
are and actually do it and not let fear
get in your way
because you're an expert on children
and what devices can do to kids and you
have
your book disconnected how to protect
your kids from the harmful effects of
device dependency i i have to ask
can you help your kids with a resolution
to do less screen time
or do you just demand it well yeah well
that's a very good question dave because
um
you know the problem with these screens
is they're designed you know to really
clutch the minds and habits of kids so
it really is the responsibility of the
parent like you could try to teach your
kids all right
you're going to be responsible with this
they're just not capable of doing it
we have to be responsible for them and
we have to hold them accountable
um you know so if your kid is playing
video games for
you know countless hours a day it's
important that parents establish a
specific rule such as right you're not
getting any more than 45 minutes a day
and if you is your kid going to give you
backlash yes but what we have to
remember
is that's part of parenting what is
screen school done
to the dependency of kids on devices
well you know 2012 when you know
smartphones really started coming on the
scene
from that point until present is is uh
when the deterioration
of the mental health among our youth
began and it has just skyrocketed out of
control epidemically
uh the coveted lockdown with kids being
you know isolated in their in their
rooms and and having online schooling
and so forth has now added another
serious layer on top of that
where the mental health and this uh
problems have skyrocketed even more
suicide is up it has been up it's even
up more now
because human beings aren't really meant
to be sort of you know imprisoned i
guess you could say you know we're more
meant to be out there
socializing interacting especially kids
and that that's kind of been stripped
away from our kids nowadays and um
you know it's a tough situation but we
have to make the best of it that if that
means
that we the parents have to spend a lot
more time interacting with our kids even
though
they don't really want to interact with
us then we have to make sure that we
that we do that for our children maybe
uh
family dinner time would be a good
resolution right
100 percent i talked talk about that
extensively in my book the importance of
sit down family meals with one another
and all the statistics on that you know
with the families that do that regularly
you know the kids are much more likely
to not have mental health issues more
likely to do better in school
um less more likely to graduate college
all these great things just from having
family dinner
uh most nights a week without any
interruptions tom
licensed psychotherapist in new jersey
happy new year thanks very much for
joining us
same to you dave my pleasure
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary
coming up hi i'm lisa brady
2020 turned out to be a turning point of
sorts for nasa
and spacex in between the surges of
covet 19
we spoke with astrophysicist neil
degrasse tyson
about that partnership and other issues
including space tourism
i hope listening gives you a little
escape from earthly concerns
a nearly decade-long drought recently
ended for nasa
three two one zero
ignition lift off spacex launching the
first
u.s astronauts from u.s soil since the
space shuttle program ended
the dragon capsule arriving at the
international space station
about 19 hours after the may 30th launch
soft capture confirmed standby for
retraction and docking
which was hailed by some as ushering in
a new era
of commercial space flight though space
tourism has already been around for two
decades now
and not everyone was quite so hyped up
about the spacex mission
it's not as though private enterprise
was never a part of
space exploration they've always been a
part of space exploration
astrophysicist neil degrasse tyson is an
author and tv
host and director of new york's hayden
planetarium
and in fact right out here on long
island i live in new york city
there's a town called bethpage where
grumman aerospace was based
they designed and built the lamb the
lunar excursion module the thing that
just
that that detached from the command
module and landed on the moon
and people to this day stand proud
you know they had an uncle an aunt a a
parent who worked there
to make that happen the difference was
this was all sort of nasa specked
and so and of course it was tax-based
paid
tax money paid for all of that so when
the rocket launched
you didn't see any private company names
on it you just saw united
states and nasa so now
um nasa says well we want to
send astronauts back to the space
station who's got a rocket
so now spacex right here we got a rocket
and so does it meet the specs fine i
mean
you know is it safe yes so the
difference
is that nasa is shopping for its
hardware
rather than being the creator of it but
when people
look at this and think private
enterprise opening a new frontier that's
not quite
right so far i think only the russian
space agency has sent a tourist
into space and there have been several
where do you stand on space
tourism tourism is probably the first
door you would open to commercialize
space
okay i mean space is already
commercialized in the sense that we have
like direct tv
right there's satellites giving you
images and those are privately owned and
privately launched
so it's not as though commercial
enterprise hasn't entered
space and look at uber uber would not
exist were it not for space assets
specifically the gps satellites but
if you want humans in space i'm thinking
tourism right and and if you want to
turn a space program into a space
industry you got to find ways that
people are going to want to spend their
disposable money on space assets
and so tourism would be a very um uh
potent way to begin that and then maybe
you'd open
up asteroids for asteroid mining right
all kinds of resources are on asteroids
stuff that we dig hard on earth to find
and we're running out of
there's plenty plenty of that on
asteroids so there's there's definitely
a future there
and i've said many times i think the
world's first trillionaire
will be the first person who exploits
the natural resources on asteroids
yeah i mean and when it comes to space
tourism it's not like right now
you know a lot of us have a spare 20
million
or so to go take a ride in space
that was the ticket if i remember
correctly i think you did your homework
on that one
um but i mean i because i think the
first space tourist i mean i didn't
realize it had been so long i think it
was dennis
tito if i had to have his name right in
yeah yeah i mean that's 19 years ago
yes yes yes well we needed the um also
the space station as a place to visit
so the space station wasn't really
completed until 20 years ago so
um but but yeah so here's the thing
right not everyone has 20 million if you
have a billion yeah 20 million is lunch
money
but every dollar less than 20 million
there's somebody who can afford that
right so if one person does it for
20 million might there be five people
who do it for 10 million
and then 10 people who do it
for 5 million right and you keep coming
down the ladder
and then maybe a hundred people would do
it for a million
but now they keep dropping it maybe it's
a hundred thousand dollars
okay or fifty thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars
what do you spend to fly the family on a
week-long vacation
right there's hotel there's airfare
there's car
there's it adds up you're in the
multiple thousands of dollars at that
point
would you forego two years of saved
money for
vacations for one trip into space i bet
you will
for example so so the i think economic
economist would say it's a highly
elastic
demand well there's a company called
space adventures that has worked with
russia
on you know sending people into space
now they have a new deal
for a trip to the space station that
would include a space
walk and a russian cosmonaut would be
with
the space walking tourist but astronauts
train for years to do what they do i
mean is this just getting into territory
that's a little too risky
yes on some level but let's let's
rethink
what you just said in a nut in a in a
fresh light
all right we all saw the movie or read
the book the right stuff
right and you know what do those
astronauts go through there's a
centrifuge
and they're left out in the wilderness
and there's survival training and
and all this well that's in case
the the the capsule
doesn't enter orbit and it lands in the
desert
okay that's why they go through that
training
just in case stuff goes wrong in a bad
way and that was an entirely new
frontier
so now no that's not going to happen and
even if it does
land somewhere um uncomfortable
we'll pick you up within an hour okay
we have total access to basically
everywhere on earth with planes and
helicopters and ships and
so no you don't need a week of survival
training i mean to
to be able to survive a week and eat
bugs right no that's just not necessary
so so the right stuff can just be sort
of the adequate stuff
today right if you want to think about
it in those terms
and the safer the mission is and the
more flexible the spacesuits are and the
more efficiently that's all
constructed i don't see why a
physically fit ordinary person couldn't
then do what the astronauts today
are doing do you think that this
horrible
pandemic we're really still in the
middle of we'll give
people some new perspective about our
place in the universe
and i ask this partly because there's an
actual view from space
being offered by three space agencies
including nasa
showing changes environmental
agricultural
that you can see from space as this
tragedy
has unfolded on the planet with covet my
my hope is that this will be an excuse
for people to
yeah maybe we should listen to
scientists going forward
not only that you can think of covid as
an
alien invader no it's earth-based yes
but what would an alien invader do they
would come to earth
and they won't care what your skin color
is or what god you worship
on on what day of the week or where you
live on earth
they're an invader they're attacking
everybody
so if you have an alien invader
attacking everybody
you have to come together as a species
to protect yourself it requires
cooperation
it requires a level of communication and
cooperation that is not common
in geopolitics so for me
it's an excuse to to sort of oil the
hinges
of or or the the moving parts
of international cooperation
uh because what does it mean for you we
we wanting to kill one another
when there's something else that wants
to kill us both
okay what an occasion to like hold hands
and
and defend earth and ourselves so covet
if enough people thought about covet in
that way
i think that could transform
international politics possibly
permanently
for it for the better you know i find it
really hard
to wrap my head around our place in the
universe
like just how tiny even our entire solar
system is
in the grand scheme of things um
there's nothing wrong with you for not
being able to do that you
i'm not the only one
[Laughter]
do you think you're just fine all right
you think there's life on other other
planets in other
solar systems and galaxies i'm given no
reason to doubt
that likelihood because when you study
the problem
all all parameters of that problem
point to the affirmative
in the in the chances of there being
life for example
you know what are we made of well
hydrogen and
nitrogen and oxygen and and calcium
these are some of the most common
ingredients
in the universe so we're not made of
anything special
and how how long did it take life
to arise after it had its first chance
to do so
maybe 100 million years we see this from
the fossil records
um 100 million sounds like a long time
but the earth has been around for four
and a half
billion that's a very small fraction of
the total time we've been around
and so earth almost as early as it
possibly could have
figured out a way to make life we still
don't know how to do it in the
laboratory but earth figured it out
so we have the time on our favor we have
the
the fact that nature did it quickly we
have the ingredients
in our favor for answering yes to that
question
so that's why any astrophysicist will
not deny that likelihood
well neil degrasse tyson what a
wonderful pleasure to get to talk to you
astrophysicist director of new york's
hayden planetarium
and let's not forget host of star talk
thank you so much for your time thank
[Music]
you
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
small simple acts of kindness sometimes
have a ripple effect that travels the
globe
take for instance the blue refrigerator
that sits outside a hockey academy on
wusang street in hong kong
it's filled with packets of instant
noodles biscuits tins of food and even
socks and towels for those who might
need them
on the front of the fridge there's a
sign that reads give what you can give
take what you need to take the
associated press who reported this story
says
amen khan is the one who created this
community refrigerator
after seeing a film about other people
doing the same thing khan is the founder
of a sports foundation that's located on
wusung street
and he found the fridge at a garbage
collection point and painted it blue
he says the project is about dignity and
he wants everyone to know the feeling of
security like when they can go home
open their fridge and get food his blue
refrigerator project has gone viral on
social media and people drop by just to
leave food inside
some people leave snacks others leave
masks to keep their community safe from
covet 19.
one woman who was leaving a donation was
asked by the ap
why she was doing it she said quote a
small
act can already show our kindness and
contribute to this world
something to take with us into 2021
tanya j
powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind president-elect joe
biden
like most americans is probably thinking
about new year's resolutions
here are 10 helpful suggestions i would
make
number one please stop stop that little
jog you do when approaching a podium
we get it that you want to appear
youthful but tom cruise you're not
ditto the aviator glasses channeling top
gun is so 1980s
those glasses are not only dated they
make you look shifty which is a truly
terrible idea
especially with so many legitimate
questions swirling around you
and your son hunter your brother jim
and what you did or did not know about
the family trying to cash in on your
white house gig
in ukraine and china the liberal media
won't ask you about those activities or
whether you are
as tony bublinski claimed the big guy
who was to be cut in on a shady chinese
money maker
but that doesn't mean those questions
won't dog your presidency
number three speaking of the media
resolve to host a normal press
conference sometime
soon do this without a teleprompter
without wife jill at your side without
pre-arranged questions and rehearsed
answers
relax let the fur fly you can count on a
mainly fawning liberal press
if there are a few challenging questions
just call the reporters dog-faced pony
soldiers
and leave them guessing seems to work
every time
number four stop saying that a 100-day
national mask mandate will magically
stop the spread of cobit 19.
some 80 percent or more of the country
already wears masks and the figure is
above
90 percent in high risk areas number
five resolve that you will stop
pretending to be the candidate
and now the president-elect for the
little guy
you took tens of millions of dollars
from big business and big tech
the ultimate special interest you so
frequently rail against
number six please stop referring to
kamala harris as the president-elect as
you have done on several occasions
it's confusing and frankly your election
is plenty bewildering as it is
it is also for much of the country
downright scary
number seven please joe resolve to stop
reminiscing about the good old days in
the situation room
and suggesting that gathering folks in
that storied white house locale
will fix all of our problems i get it
that you remember fondly your times in
that space sitting alongside your buddy
barack
even if most of your suggestions on key
events like the raid that killed osama
bin laden
were completely ignored number eight
promise to not offer hillary clinton a
job in your administration
i know she said she's quote ready to
help unquote
but bringing her in would be a horror
show and would certainly not unite the
country as you have vowed to do
number nine resolve that john kerry is
forbidden
under any circumstances to again haul
james taylor
out of retirement to croon you've got a
friend
that was then secretary of state kerry's
plan to assuage the enraged french
people
when obama failed to join more than 40
heads of state
in a solidarity march following the
charlie head bow terrorist attacks
number 10 you have often said that you
wish to bring the country together
you might start mr president-elect by
trying to understand
why over 74 million people voted for
president trump
and respect the policies of his
administration that have been successful
like the brilliant abraham accords at
the end of the day
all americans should want this country
to be stronger safer
and more successful for everyone
achieving that goal
is how you can actually bring the nation
together
happy new year joe this is liz peake
columnist and fox contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
that's the perino and stir walt i'll
tell you what podcast
dana perino of the five and fox news
political editor chris stirwald
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes